[Applause]
same thing is happening hollywood right
now did you see like the new uh
uh the new requirements to to have like
an oscar
oh your requirements to have an emmy you
have to do this like it has to be
super like diverse cast and all this
other kind of [ __ ] what i don't
understand is why the performative
action because people will still support
you you just got to appease
people will give you money but if
people aren't watching the woke [ __ ]
right
why continue to make it that i don't get
and that's what always bothered me about
it is
i can understand its show business
that's what we're always told yes
but when the business isn't productive
being woke then you should change your
business
that's what i don't understand the daily
show ratings have been dog [ __ ]
since jon stewart left right but you
keep
this show afloat even though it does bad
business with its performative super
left wokeness
yeah it's bad for business why are you
letting it do this why is this your
anchor show for this network do you
think that
they're so like locked in their bubble
in hollywood that they don't realize the
rest of the world hates them
i do think that about actors but the
people funding the movies can i say one
thing bruh
i can't say the guy's name because i
gotta you know look out for my dude
not my dude i don't know but i have
actors hit me up
yeah complaining about this kind of [ __ ]
right they can't say anything publicly
because they're working within
that sphere but they're like this is
absolute [ __ ]
they we can't believe it like actors
that you wouldn't know
right not like guys who can't get work
you got to tell me i love the podcast
i'll tell you and i would say
but i don't want to just yes and you
don't snitch on anybody right
but they're calling out how stupid it is
and i'm just like yo what is the deal
why are they doing this performative
[ __ ] like if you're a government i
understand you can do
performative acts to better the lives of
certain groups of people because you
don't have to rely
on making money but if you're a business
you have to make money now that these
things are not making money
eventually you're going to run out of
money yeah eventually you're going to
have to make some [ __ ] that people want
to consume
and i i keep waiting for that tipping
point and they just when the [ __ ] is
going to happen
i don't get it i don't get it it's
mind-boggling to me i mean we keep
benefiting from their stupidity because
people keep finding
us i love it but i just don't from a
business standpoint i'm like what are
y'all doing
i understand show business this is bad
business
now i will say though like i think
there's a subset if you wanted to make a
movie
about like some disability [ __ ] because
you're like oh no one looked like me and
you're able to like help someone and you
want to do it it's like an art project
then yeah go do it but to try to try to
create like some sort of like
legislation or like if it's authentic
i'm with it yeah exactly
it is what are you talking about with
disability
like what do you mean like i was i was
talking to this i was talking to my
sister who works
with this kid who doesn't have an arm
okay and he was like oh when i was a kid
there was this movie about a kid that
didn't have an arm and i liked it yes
even though the movie wasn't that
successful
it was just a movie about a kid that
have an arm he's like oh yeah that's
like me it felt good
yeah yeah like when you said with
aladdin you're like it was cool to see
someone that kind of looked like you
close enough
yes yeah that's that's how i felt with
jason williams yeah people think white
people don't have that feeling but like
the basketball player jason williams i
was like oh sick there's a guy who plays
basketball in a way i kind of play
basketball
you know so it was cool to see everybody
has that feeling everybody wants a right
yeah i think that we get lost in this
idea where like uh
since white people are like the
executive roles in a lot of these
companies i think that like
maybe i can't speak for you maybe
minorities think that like we get
excited by that
no white people aren't going yeah we're
the refs
yeah that's my favorite ref i feel
represented no there are definitely yeah
that's the owner
there are definitely arenas where white
people are like oh [ __ ] it's cool to see
this but like
it's a different one like you never saw
this 100 so that's what we're saying
you guys definitely go through it though
like i think everybody goes through it
when
you like an industry that doesn't have
someone that's kind of like you
in it eminem meant something to a lot of
people so many white people say he's the
greatest rapper ever he's great yeah but
they cling to greatest ever because
that's their guy
this is finally i've been listening this
music my whole life finally a guy that
looks like me in this field that's
good yeah yes that's good yeah so and
great he's great
like that's the guy that's our guy yeah
everybody does this yeah you feel some
like
i don't know is it more entitlement do
you feel like you feel like you belong
it's like it's seeing a brown person on
in american movies and stuff i was
always like holy [ __ ] that means
something to me that's me
you know what did you know what's dope
about uh olympics for that reason
is that like when you watch the olympics
you get to
take part in that person's success
as an american yeah like within the
country you're we're all chopped up into
these little teams and groups
right you know you're indian you know
like i'm white alex is black but latino
like
mark is catholic and like maybe when a
catholic does something cool
you know what i mean maybe i don't know
i don't know if you know they talk about
that [ __ ] they do
yeah they'll be like oh yeah like this
catholic guy like they just talk about
like the supreme court
there's a ton of catholics in the
supreme court they're like look at us oh
because uh scalia was kind of yeah
exactly it's all about like catholic
schools boom so there's like this like
cool like
i guess a little tribalism everybody
gets in their tribe right taylor you
might see a black woman do something
that you represent
or like you respect and you're like oh
that kind of represents me that's dope
right but the cool thing about the
olympics
is in it's kind of similar to war which
is like
when you're competing against other
bigger tribes yes we all put our [ __ ]
all our guys fade
right and we're just like all right is
he nice yeah is he the fastest
i don't care he's asian he's india he's
black he's like whatever just put him
out there let's meritocracy we didn't
know who
apollo ono was remember that guy he was
a speed skater
i don't know what the [ __ ] he was
michael phelps goofy ass look like me
but you ever make fun of somebody the
way they look and then people start
saying you look like them yes
and you feel [ __ ] humiliated that
guy's mouth doesn't close how does he
swim
the guy has a hole in the boat
collecting water it's unbelievable so uh
but it's just a cool thing about the
olympics man is it like for a second we
get to take back and we get to all
have pride yeah in what was created
and i think the reason why it's okay to
do that is because like
it came we came up within the american
system
you know it's like there was that time
where uh in it was the world cup i think
france won the world cup right and there
was all this conversation like
yeah but it won with all african guys
right but
yes maybe that their dna their genes
were african but
you have to credit the french system
that they came up under
and they taught them and the tutelage
and the training and all these things
that they didn't get in those african
countries and if the french people
celebrate them that's a huge win for
diversity in france everybody should
want that you should want people that
don't look like they're from that
country to do
to excel so then they feel more accepted
in that country yeah probably yeah don't
be silly
this is africa winning if you're french
don't do that because why would they
embrace france
yeah yeah and also on the other side and
and also don't allow
someone to remove your patriotism from
you yeah
i don't like that like you are entitled
you can't say
we want the rights and respect that we
are deserved
as citizens of this country and have a
goal to reject the country
does that make sense like you should be
allowed to be patriotic yeah
and not call the sell out for that but
embrace for that yeah and then when
the arrangement when the deal that all
of us as citizens with the country is
not met by the country
then we hold the country accountable
yeah well said but you do not have to
to sell your patriotism or like give up
your patriotism like it's a beautiful
[ __ ] thing
right yeah it's something i noticed when
i'm watching football this weekend where
i'm seeing all these guys some of them
kneeling some of them standing all
holding hands and all this other stuff
and i'm like
yo did we actually come to a really cool
conclusion here like
did we come to a place and i'm not
talking about like the performance [ __ ]
the nfl did i'm literally talking about
the players
standing next to each other some holding
hands telling them hands with hearts
someone kneeling
and they're all together and it's like
oh we just realized that you could
treat different things you could treat
the same thing in different ways and it
can all be respectful
yeah it took us four years yeah and
blackball
and kaepernick yeah but we got to it i
think is a pretty cool place
yeah yeah so i think representation is
important in that way
yeah however what makes the academy
awards thing or the oscar thing where
they say you have to have certain things
frustrating is that it seems like they
are like requiring or like
forcing representation i feel like
you're taking pity on me personally when
you do that and it's like i don't
want that how about this though how
about this
instead of making the requirement for
the movie
um that the actors have to be a certain
whatever
why stop at actors the producers
of the studio have to have diversity on
their boards
because what is it 90 we did it when we
did it yes
98 of executives on uh in the
studios in hollywood for different
studio companies i'm talking about the
studios the company that makes the
actual
there's no no black presidents except
spike lee i think spike lee was the only
one
and he made his own company yeah of his
own i mean tyler perry imagine as a
studio as well but he made his own
so there's no black president of any of
these companies so
why don't you put that performative
racism
sorry performative activism to task on
yourself
because they don't care about activism
they care about money and
no no no it's not money oh gosh it's
protecting their
little seat boy band exactly so what i
think that they're doing is going
if we if we put diversity in these
little roles that are replaceable that
we don't care about we can keep hiring
our friends
yeah we have this little boy's quality i
agree just to be accurate uh they do
have other standards it's standard b
that has creative leadership
and in the project team and then they
also have another standard c
industry access and opportunities so
it's not just um actors and
in front screen people so it's like more
access for executive board
like i want the executive board highest
highest level because with the highest
highest level
right the real change makers and it
seems to me that it's all performative
activism to protect their [ __ ]
right it's like oh yeah let the athletes
be the ones that are sponsoring
that we're sponsoring and that let them
be the face of the company but don't put
them on the board
yep uh al you're black
and that i am speak for all blacks speak
for every one of them
no no seriously though like what what do
you feel when you see this and the same
thing with for akash it's like
you guys benefit from these measures so
i'm sure on some part you're like
well this is dope because i get a piece
of the pie
and on the other part you're like well
you don't have to pity me i could get
mine
like you guys are guys are hustlers so
i'm curious what your well i mean it's
for
minorities women lgbt that snuck into
this
they got snuck into it as well so it's
like they sneak them babies it's
basically
women everybody except white women
[Laughter]
we went here hi yo this is all good bro
we got all different types of newbie and
queens
back to the academy award thing i do
like the fact that they're finally doing
something about
representation there because when you
look at any one of those awards the
whole [ __ ] is white
like the majority of most of the winners
the majority of people there and the
audience are white so it's just gay the
whole thing is a [ __ ] sham
dawg like i understand about this [ __ ]
understand all
of that i'm just saying i'm just saying
all these like i always see people be
upset when they don't win an
oscar they don't win like an emmy you
see these like rappers who like
literally create the culture
dictate culture they create the whole
way that people are dressing
acting vernacular people are using and
then some white
stiff that's 70 years old doesn't say i
like your album and they have a freak
out over it who the [ __ ] cares
you would never give a [ __ ] about that
white guy's opinion at any other point
especially in music i don't know who has
any grammys it helps them get paid more
i got no [ __ ] clue
i loved it when they did the sippy cup
[ __ ] yo but it helps them get paid daisy
was like oh we got a sippy cup for blue
yeah if you're an academy award winner
you get paid more now if you gave me one
minute you're broke afterwards no you
get
hillary swank what do you do
like there is a thing that happens where
like a lot of people win academy awards
and then their careers don't do anything
because
the movies that end up winning are these
like artsy goofy shits yeah that nobody
really gives a [ __ ] or watching even
jamie foxx after ray i don't remember
him
popping like crazy movie after movie
after movie but i'm pretty sure you can
demand more
after year and again give me i'd rather
be an independence day than the artist
100 any day of the week blockbuster bro
transformers dog i don't need to be in
the fight
i hate the fact that it's forced but i
just like that they're trying to do
something
yeah you like the fake effort behind it
i like the effort behind it i just like
that it's
but you really want um black stories to
be told that different minorities
stories to be told then put the people
that are green lighting those stories
put people of those minorities in
position to greenlight those stories
yeah i agree with that too so then just
change up by the top it's trickled down
with this [ __ ]
oh you put black people but that's what
i'm saying they haven't done either
so the fact that they're trying to say
something measure over no matter yeah
that's fair i hear you that's all
that's the wrong measure who's the uh
what's the blackest channel on
on uh network television right now most
likely
abc right network i'm saying network
network obviously
but uh probably bt right or no probably
abc right
president of abc black woman black woman
that's all it is bro
you put the people of those races in
positions of power to green light their
stories
they will green light those stores but
if you don't change that
all this [ __ ] down here performative
it's cute people get some money but it's
not going to be long-term change
and to her credit probably the only
shows
on network tv that are doing well right
now ish
all that issues are killing bro yeah but
they had to get away with murder
they had another what was it scandal
shonda
shonda trying to let them know what was
capable i think was possible
you